[Music]
now you might think it's time to stop
talking about politicians breaking
covert rules but the reason it's still
an important story is because of the
ordinary brits who are still going
through the courts to deal with their
own inconsequential fines
michael simmons the spectator's data
journalist looks at this in this week's
magazine michael joins me now
so michael we've just been talking about
beer gate and party gate and a lot of
people i think are getting quite bored
with these stories thinking they're
quite trivial but you make the point in
your sidebar to katie balls's cover
piece this week that actually a lot of
people are still getting fined for
transgressions that were even less than
having a beer or having a birthday cake
can you tell us about these the cases
that are still going through the courts
right now from covert
yeah so absolutely um
basically because a lot of the the
courts were obviously shot during the
lockdowns and the general um court
backlog built up it's exactly the same
with people that were fined during the
lockdowns and during the tiered
restrictions a lot of those cases are
kind of only just getting through the
court system now so in the weeks where
kind of party gate's been going on we've
still seen um that these 136 000 fines
across britain are being dealt with and
there's some kind of really interesting
examples of you know
fines for ridiculous things fines where
you think the people are buying to write
and finds that are really similar to um
what's happened in partygate and
beergate and some of the examples on the
kind of bigger end and there was a
student in leeds was fined ten thousand
pounds because as he says for a joke he
made this um facebook event to say oh
let's have a big snowball fight and then
within a couple of hours he thought this
joke's a bad idea it's got out of hand
so he deleted the event but and hundreds
of people turned up to this park where
the snowball fight was to be anyway and
he ended up with um a ten thousand pound
fine
um
on the 18th of december which is the day
of one of the downing street alleged
christmas parties um a pub in devon also
had its own christmas party and the
landlord of the pub ended up with four
thousand pounds worth of fines and he's
kind of really miffed about this because
as far as we know nobody in downing
street has been fined more than 50
pounds so far so there's kind of the
question about there seems to be a
certain discrepancy between between
fines
the other interesting thing with the
fines is if you do choose to contest
your fine which by the way most people
don't from the data we've seen only
about two percent of fines actually get
contested and then you end up going
through the court processes the judges
are kind of not really interested in
much mitigation or what your actual
covert risk war was so as an example and
the regulation about not being in
gatherings of more than two people and a
judge has said you know in court
documents that there's essentially no
defense to this if you're with more than
two people
and then that's you uh you've broken the
law and a couple of kind of harrowing
examples of this and one was an elderly
man and who was quite he said he felt
quite lonely and he went to visit his
allotment and there he was found
chatting to people at the allotment and
he ended up with a fine similarly there
was a lady who had been helping with
child care with somebody who was in a
support bubble which was allowed and it
was the child's birthday so she went
round to the mother's house
and to drop off a birthday card she
didn't go in the house she says and but
when she got there she didn't realize
that the the person she went to see had
guests around illegally and because she
was essentially caught on the doorstep
she ended up with a fine and again the
magistrate judges are kind of not
interested or they don't seem to be as
interested in these defenses and the
people all end up being fined it's
incredible because the examples you have
you know people's fines obviously range
from the customary 100 pounds which is
50 pounds if you pay it in half the
amount of time to 10 000 pounds as you
say we talk about this you know cost of
living crisis and you know i can
understand if you organize a massive
event as the student was accused of
doing you have to pay more but you know
for people like this pensioner just
being present while other people are
there outdoors which we now know is not
so bad for the virus um and the fact
that he's getting a fine 100 pounds it
does seem pretty shocking
you'd mention this discrepancy between
the devon landlord and downing street
party happening on the same day is that
because it's like a racking up of fines
as you go uh with different multiple
transgressions as it were
yeah so the the case of the the devon
landlord seemed to be that essentially
he was fined
twice on the one day
and because of kind of the severity of
him being the the owner of the pub and
the alleged um event organizer and and
then i think he then committed as
another offense that was similar so the
fines racked up and again you might say
well is this not similar to kind of some
of the alleged events we've um heard
about from downing street but what's
really interesting when you look at some
of the reporting around the court cases
is that not only can there be
discrepancy between cases there's even
cases where there's discrepancy in the
same incident so one example was from a
chippy or chip shop in notting hill
where and the owner had decided that he
needed to have a crisis meeting or what
he called a crisis meeting and to
discuss some staffing issue so all the
staff went round his house and they were
spotted and reported and the police came
and and the police felt that um this was
a meeting that although business
meetings were allowed at that time there
was no reason why this meeting wasn't
held online so the police um issued
everyone with fixed penalty notices and
some of the cases ended up going to
court and two of the staff and one
pleaded guilty um and they ended up with
a fine i think it was around 600 pounds
and but another member of staff on the
exact same evidence and didn't enter a
plea and ended up being acquitted so
actually within the same incidents we're
seeing discrepancies as well and also
across the country isn't there because
throughout all our discussion of this
we're talking about the metropolitan
police in london versus the durham
police and they have different standards
which are something that you write about
in your piece as well that durham police
has been a bit more lenient i mean the
problem at the end of the day is that
these covers rules probably just not
clear enough not well drafted enough in
order to ensure consistency when applied
across the country and you say you end
up with weird
exceptions
yes exactly so and if we look at the um
the data that's available from the
police and you do see kind of variations
and between forces and a lot of that
will have been because of the different
lock down tiers and because of
populations but for example durham
police which you mentioned i think i say
in the piece and i've so far issued
about 1 000 fines whereas in north
yorkshire which is a neighboring force
and i think is issued over 4000 so
there's that discrepancy there i think
the other issue is especially after the
first lockdown and we got to know a bit
more about covid about how it didn't
tend to track you couldn't really catch
it outdoors i think people started to
apply their own common sense and you can
argue whether they they should or
shouldn't have done that i think people
decided right if i'm going to meet
someone i'll do it outside because i'm
least at least it's safe and the problem
is the law essentially didn't allow you
to make that your own judgment and what
see it looks like anecdotally is some
police forces have sort of said okay
we'll we'll become more lenient because
of common sense where other police
forces said no we're rigidly we'll apply
everything kind of to the
letter of the law but what's interesting
as well is the attitude seems to have
changed kind of within magistrates
courts as well because if you look at
the some of the earlier cases and i saw
one count and was that only around one
percent of people were who claimed they
weren't guilty were sort of winning
their cases but now that's gone up to
about 15
so
it's kind of unlikely that oh you know
suddenly if people were 15 like less
guilty later on it's more that the kind
of magistrate's attitudes have changed
and and it's been pointed out by various
legal watchdogs that that suggests that
actually many maybe of these past fines
and convictions are sort of unjust and
perhaps even unlawful
and and it's incredible you know we talk
about this backlog in the courts that
you know transgressions like going to
your allotment and talking to your
neighbors you're still going through the
courts as you say 100 over 100 000 of
them and just finally michael what if
you decide not to pay your fine what
happens uh if you just put your foot
down and say
i'm going to appeal but my appeal has
been a failure but i'm just not going to
pay the fine
yeah so if you don't pay and within your
28 days and you will probably end up
with a case before the magistrates
courts
and the majority of these cases are
dealt with for this legal mechanism
called the single justice procedure and
that's a procedure that's it's designed
really to keep people sort of out of
actual courtrooms
and and it's designed more for things
like a non-payment of the license fee
and people have been quite critical of
this single justice procedure because it
means that your case isn't heard in open
court essentially it's done what as they
call on the papers you sort of write in
your play and your evidence and then um
a magistrate and a legal adviser will
kind of sit and adjudicate and and
that's not really done in a courtroom in
earlier stages of pandemic you know
literally the magistrate could be um
working from home and it was really hard
to find out through public court
listings where these were going on and
in westminster magistrates as an example
they ended up designating this on their
court lists as courtroom 78 which isn't
a physical courtroom that actually
exists so in insiders kind of say this
has now become the name for these cases
as oh it's a courtroom 78 case
and you say that what you know you can
just if you missed the letter you could
just not know that you you've been
served one of these and one man found
out that he was being fined through his
local paper
yeah absolutely so um i think the mail
had reported this that there was uh
there's a man in reading who i think it
was a fairly minor and misdemeanor that
he kind of committed and with these
single justice procedures there's no
sort of requirement for you to be served
with papers or for like receipt of
papers so if you get this fine you don't
pay it because like you say that you've
not received any court documents and the
court will still hear your case assume
you're not engaging and then you can be
issued with your fine and local
newspapers will go through these kind of
charge lists and report you know such
and such joe blogs and has received this
fine and this unfortunate man you know
discovered that he'd been fined were
literally for reading his local paper
incredible michael simmons thank you so
much for joining spectator tv
[Music]
you